so let's switch say two different
subject so first I'd really like to
thank again the dog neither of their
workshop and also the organizer for the
tutorial for putting up such a nicer to
Talia and so this is going to be the
last talking this at all and i'm going
to talk about slightly different topic
then and what you saw throughout this
week i'm going to talk about interactive
communication in networks okay so this
entire week we talked about the
two-party case so i guess i need not
explain it again we have a listen Bob
that each one has some input they want
to interact to compute some function
that's what we were doing this entire
week this talk I want to talk about the
multi-party case now instead of having
godessohn Bob we have Charlie and who
dig good so have many people let's say
sleep for for just one example they are
connected to each other each one has
this input and I want to compute some
function of the joint input ok so don't
like although I droid that way I don't
want you to think that they must be all
connected to each other we may have some
any arbitrary topology so we can
formulate it as a graph of n nodes each
node will be a party and each edge will
be a communication link and directional
so if p1 and p2 are connected both can
send and receive bits with each other
but p2 cannot send bits to p4 ok and
again each one gets his own input and
they want to compute some a function of
the joint inputs so the multi-party
interactive communication the thing is
that we have quite a plenty of modeling
issues here so let me just tell you
about some of them so how do we
bout is performed the computational
performative using some protocol for a
pie and the protocol can be synchronous
in in this case we have rounds we have
time notion and at every round each
party sends a bit on each of these
communication channels okay but there is
also the asynchronous model where there
is no notion of time and then whenever
will receive a message you can send
message to all your message all your
neighbors but you don't have to send
message you can keep silent in the
asynchronous model do you still have a
notion of the rounds no because there is
no time okay so that was the multi-party
interactive communication now let's talk
about noisy multi multi party
interactive communication so now this
communication channel may be noisy and
again we have some modeling choices how
do we move their noise so as you already
so by now we can assume that the noise
is stochastic so this is the random
noise on for instance is each
communication channel is a BSC this
probability of flipping the beats
Epsilon it could be a sour noise when we
have only a global amount of bit flips
this is the harming model we can also
have something in between for instance
we can restrict the noise / link we can
assume that each link suffers from some
epsilon fraction of big flips okay so
there's plenty of Phil to to talk about
and let me see what we wanted one what
do we want to achieve so the goal
encoding as as before is the following
assume that we have some protocol that
works if there is no noise what we want
to do we want to construct a new
protocol that is resilient to noise and
as before we want to discuss the main
parameter we discuss should be the rate
how much redundancy we add by
making the protocol noise resilient and
that is just the communication of the
old one divided by the communication of
the new one just as in the two parties I
think so our goal what we would like to
have with this new resilient protocol we
would like to have first of all we would
like to make this new zealand protocol
succeed either with probability 1 or
with high probability for instance if
the noise is random and we also want the
way to be high Oh at least not vanishing
not not 0 so I will say that the wreck
is not vanishing if when we assume that
the number of parties goes to infinity
and the length of the original protocol
may go also to infinity then we want
delayed to be nonzero strictly positive
i will sometime call it concentrate but
when i say constant I mean positive
constant it's positive light okay so let
me serve a some of the results and let
me begin with the case of random noise
the two schemes I will actually spend
most of my time explaining what is to
skim do the first one is biological
initial man from the 90s it assumes a
synchronous model and random noise it
works for any topology and assume that
the maximal degree of the graph is d
then it gives us rate of 1 over log D
another resolved by alone bother man fmn
call myself and hope we now we don't
walk this skin doesn't work for any
topology only for d regular graph and
assuming that the mixing time is M it
gives rate that goes like 1 over m cube
log M I will give more details about
these two in a minute but before going
there let me just and okay before that
sorry so yeah so I said we want the rate
to be non vanishing ought to be positive
these two code schemes imply coding with
positive light for many colleges
not to all of them for instance we can
get each time the day is constant with
this coding scheme will get us a
positive rate coding scheme for instance
for the case of a line cycle or any
constant the decree graph however here
we will get constant plate where the
mixing when the mixing time is constant
so this will give us a positive rate
coding fo for instance for complete
graph so random graphs with with degree
n to the alpha for any a positive alpha
etc ok so few words about the odd case
of adversarial laws and as you can see
all these results are from the last
three four five months so the first to
walk in the asynchronous model he'll
this result assumes we have a style at
least it assumes that the graph is a sub
graph which is a style it resists one
over N up to a constant one of an
infraction of noise and they actually
show that you cannot resist more than
one over at nine this kind of trivial
because with one of the rain function of
noise you can just pick one of the
parties and completely co-op that party
so one of the other line is the maximal
noise that multi-party schemes can
suffer and I get positive rate for for
their model this result in the middle
they also use the a synchronous model
they slice it they achieve a complete
graph in the end they get the same
parameters and I will not get to the
difference between these two mainly
because it's really a new result and I'm
still not understanding it well enough
and another walk bye-bye house and
Sherman and this walk walks in the
synchronous model and adversarial noise
it works for any topology it achieves
the maximal possible noise rate however
the rate is n over
m log n with m is the number of edges so
this doesn't give concentrate for all
topologies but for some of them it does
no sorry yes yes yes right okay so as I
said I'm going now to talk about these
two so let's let's just fix the model
because I told you about too many models
and they don't want you to be too
confused so what I'm going to talk about
this about in this talk so we are going
to assume the synchronous model again we
have a notion of time we have rounds let
every allowance every party can sense a
bit on every channel that it is
connected to so p1 can send bit p2 to p3
n2 before these bits can be different he
doesn't need to send the same bit to all
of them we will assume random noise so
each communication channel here is a BSc
with a flipping probability epsilon and
again the goal is if somebody gives us a
protocol that works if when there is no
noise we want to have to compile it into
a noise o sailin protocol that succeeds
with high probability and has high rate
great so let me begin with a with
rajagopal and Sherman a coding scheme
that was 94 just state it again so given
a network G with maximal degree D so
which party is connected to at most D
neighbors and give it a protocol pi the
text Stevens when there is no noise a
lovely we can find it most resilient by
prime that works over ABC channels and
takes out of t log D plus 1 rounds and
succeeds with high probability let me
give you some details about how this
works so the first idea is the following
we know how to do to party computer
interactive computation we had spent the
week on doing this so in multiparty
still each took parties can communicate
by themselves and make some to party
interactive communication so basically
that's what the parties do every two
parties will just turn some violent of a
two-party interactive scheme for some
order of the ones let's just set it to
city comes but it will not be the same
skin that enough was telling us about
that they sent I just it would be
slightly more simple scheme that when I
want to tell you the pass I just tell
you the path if I if my first edge is
the left one I just send zero if the
next one is the right one and send you
one so I go along a path and if I
realize that I'm i sent you the wrong
data and I actually said you drunk path
I can always send you back and back just
means that i take my past 11 step back i
backtrack my pass okay and this is sent
using three codes and using the all the
machinery that the rope was talking
about so how does this game work the
scheme works each party receives
messages from all his neighbors he
decodes what he got he plots the past
that hit he believes that the neighbor
was trying to say and then he looks at
what he got and he says okay do I know
what my next step in the past if I know
what my next step I will just send it if
I don't know I just backtrack let me
just give you an example it will make it
it will and make it more clear so let's
assume these are the first six times and
i have three neighbors p 1 p 2 in
priestly let's assume this is so I got
some symbols from p1 they are encoded
using this click odd I decode it and I
get this and this was what p1 sent to me
maybe this is not what he said to me but
that's what the trick or tells me that
he sent to me
maybe the next round I will believe that
he sent to me totally different things
that's the property of Italy code but so
far this is what I believe he sent to me
and this is what i got from p2 and this
is what i got from Pittsburgh okay so
the first thing that I do I I pass what
they say i bounce all this back crack's
so p1 said 10 10 and then he backtracked
so i removed this one this deal and then
he said 0 so that's what he said that's
what i believe is it Peter didn't say
back so this is what i believe is sad
and peacefully was saying a lot of
backwards so he actually said only 00
all the rest was deleted so my point of
view is that my neighbor said that stuff
ok but remember that until now it's 16 I
already said some stuff some of the
stuff that I said is correct some of it
is incorrect so for instance let's
assume that I send this these messages
now I can look at what i believe they
said and about what they said and check
if it makes sense so for instance look
at all this stuff this is the this
information that i already sent doesn't
make sense because I don't even know
what pc Risa is here so how could I said
this I could not guess the future and
say something that I don't know so these
things are probably incorrect but I also
check the diesel also correct and then
if everything is correct I we just send
the next thing but if things are
inconsistent like we see here definitely
this real inconsistent inconsistent I
will just tell all my all my neighbors
this and I got this wrong let's
backtrack so i will send back back back
and buy my neighbors will just remove
this one yes I'm confusable so in this
how do i how do you how does a clear
interpret the parsed this like how do
you know which what which edges a bit
scarce wanted because of the timing
chains right because ok so be every back
just removes the last undeleted bit
bit corresponding because you don't know
which round that bit yeah definitely so
we also it always gives you so this is
the past when you get out we get from
here to here from there from the second
thing from the first list from here too
but this okay yeah but was way once we
have passed we actually these are we
assumed these are the correct path in
order so this would be I assume that
this would be the first edge this would
be the second edge this would be the
servant maybe I thought right right
right this is so this is this all
totally wrong because they don't know
the selvedge maybe a thought previously
I thought that I knew but no then it was
deleted right so this changes at
everyone if the backtracking on one of
them should you be back working on all
the others because your state depends on
all the right exactly this is correct so
when you continue continue is all of
them when you backpack you sent back led
to all of your neighbors but when you
get back track you don't get back to
inform all of your neighbors because
they might not they might be on sing or
even a second message or told I don't
know which one but that you have to give
it one of them so right it is one so
well this depends if this was already
sent if this is one is the correct one
to said assuming the two wounds so these
two edges and this is my third edges if
my third edge is correct dependent on
the two previous address then I will not
delete it if it's incorrect i will
delete it and send something else okay
so now let's do some analysis so very
vaguely we can see that each arrow may
cause us to backtrack and delay the
simulation and we need to make sure that
we don't delay the simulation too much
otherwise we will not be able to
complete it in order of the rounds so
actually if we just think about the
most simple analysis we will realize
that there are too many arrows like the
health depends is proportional to the
amount of edges and this is too many but
the carrier of the analysis is that some
arrows it up while other arrows don't
add up so some else will if toils
happened some of them will cost two to
eight times a time unit of delay but
some tools will just cause one unit of
delay and when does whenever set up they
add up if they are in the influence cone
of each other what is the influence call
so if some ever happened in the next
step it affects the parties at all the
parties that connected to the party that
had an arrow in tooth in the next next
round it will affect the neighbors and
the Dean neighbors of the D neighbors
and so on this will be the influence
cone it's like well how the information
propagates okay so to understand a
little bit why some arrows that up in
some not let's have an example so soon
with all parties there is one round it
all parties get an arrow all of them at
the same time now let's assume that on
the next round the three codes saves us
and all of them realize that they had an
arrow and all of them back up so we lost
one round of delay we backed everybody
back track so you just only one round
although Nao's happened because this app
I was didn't add up because they are not
in the influence corner of each other
they are aside ok so maybe to visualize
this I took this picture from the
original paper you can see so what we
have here we have simple line on each
party is connected to the professor to
the processors next to it so this will
be the processors and each one is
connected to one to the left and one
party to the right and this will be the
time let's assume this X is the narrow
and
the black squares are just the
backtracking so if this guy had an L
then he realizes and he backtracks and
he sends back trick to his neighbors and
you can see that the influence corn here
it causes a wave of back backtracking
when do I was adopts we you know we had
an arrow here and then we backed up and
then you know in the influence convey
the northern ever we need to back up
again this is already two levels of
delay so actually the amount of time
will back up is if we look at the
influence cone of fun party and we can
look at all the lines the amount of
arrows along this line in the influence
will determine how many times we
backtrack and we just need to make sure
that we don't backtrack too many times
ok so the same but bye-bye us is that if
simulation failed it must have been the
case that at least that many arrows
happened and this happened on the line
that add up so this many l's that ed up
must have happened ok
um so what is the probability that
simulation first let's let's just count
how many lines how many such lines we
have and then realize how what is the
probability to have the event too many
arrows happened across one line so if n
parties this is just the history cone so
one party is connected to D on the first
round those they are connected to this
square I mean it each step you can
create in case by multiplying by D so
this is just the history that just the
influence cone these are the amount of
ways to have these many rounds these
many arrows within city rounds right and
this is the probability parallel to the
probability to have city or a 4 l's
right if it ever happens with
probability P ro and we know all of them
get this probability this event to have
small probability we just need the
probability of error of a singular ought
to be slow able to be very small we just
need PE to be less than poly / 10 / d
right and this one gives us the rate of
flogged d in this scheme because in
order to make the single L so small we
need to send each bit something like
lagdi times right so we send each bit
log.d times and we have CT rounds and
this what gives us there the weight vest
and sun on the other skin
yeah so we assume that this way larger
than n so all of these off to the power
of tea and and it gives us a log-log and
there but is way larger than log of n
people on to see tebow thought most and
learn to put your cone can never be
larger than ten right yes yes but but
this will give this will give this two
things will give to to this 2 to the
power of of T up to a constant so tell
me not just a man can be louder than I
mean like a mess up so easy you in the
uncorrupted case message can go back and
forth back and forth back and forth oh
sorry that the comb can be but but I
mean at some point this will will become
n right it will become that any step you
just multiply by n it doesn't increase
it ok so Oh am I was the time oh good so
that's the obvious 94 let me summarize
so it gives like it it can compile any
protocol to a noise resilient that works
with high probability of a b c that's
the how many rounds it takes so when do
we get a constant right we can
concentrate whatever these is a constant
right however in the worst case for
instance when we have a complete graph
then the equals n and we get x we get a
late which goes to 0 1 over log n yeah
so another thing this scheme is not
efficient because it assumes the
machinery of three codes however it can
be made efficient using the machinery of
potent records I think there was a
question about it a couple of days ago
so in case of random noise we know how
to do
three codes that can be a constructed
and decoded inefficient time this is
joint work with Uncle metronomy too high
ok so now let's move to the other
protocol that I wants to talk about I
will call it the A+ coding scheme apply
stands for the a B EGA so it's a LAN
driver money Fomenko myself in her
player we are still missing C D and F so
we take applications to get get a strike
and okay so let me just dive into the
serum a series of topology is a debug
you log off and assume that it has
mixing time m I will say in a second
what mixing time means if you if you
don't know then there exists an
efficient coding scheme with late one of
the MQ blog m and high success
probability and mixing time mixing time
just means that if you started some node
and take a random walk of em steps you
will end up more or less everywhere with
the same probability we will end it
every node with probability almost won
over them yes what we want um so we get
concentrate ok so m is constant for many
many graphs for instant for the complete
graphs well I was 94,000 get good right
we will get a positive constant rate of
a random yeah
you see that makes sense i got is
regular general No Limit distribution is
proportional to your degree so this
definition is a little bit right but we
receive a regular gough did I get off
only tier ago it's not the regular
vanilla free to mention of it is so true
yeah now in the inter case it will not
walk in if it's if we are not endearing
allow it what again it has to be exactly
d regular there can be it can be
directly they could be you but you
cannot have like what a lot of degree n
and all that were those would you up you
cannot be stopped that's another way to
fake yes so for the line the others 94
volt that he gives us a coding scheme is
good rate so but no we this scheme will
not give good result and i'll tell you
why so okay so how do we prove this
theorem our starting point is actually
looking of what I told you about RS 94
and let me just restate the servant that
I told you then so I'm saying that you
can also imply the following so if a
single round of the noiseless protocol
can be simulated using let's say K noise
around with good probability 1 minus PE
where we want to have PE negligible in n
let's say then any T round protocol in
Tehran noiseless protocol can be
simulated using order of KT noise rounds
with very high probability so what I
showed you in showman I we just will
bound in the probability of single arrow
so obviously if we bound the probability
that all parties at one loud 6222
transmit the debate we are in a better
shape and then in what I hope you will
be needed to be less than one of your
poly d so obviously if it's
rebellion and we are all in a better
shape so this is a corollary of what I
tell you but what it means it means that
that we only need to show how to
simulate a single round of the noises
protocol in order to be done what's the
single round every party has one bit to
send to each of his neighbor's if we
show how to deliver this bit reliably
with K steps we will be done and in curl
a blow-up of K so if I show you how to
do it with constant number of steps the
probability go yes yes so so this
actually yes yes because as you the
power of protocol is longer used to
spell transmit more and more information
so think about transmitting one bit if
you just consume it one bit it will fail
this probability Epsilon but if it
transmit it n times it will fail this
you will be able to decode correctly its
mobility epsilon to the to the N and
over to unusual this protocol is very
long the probabilities are just unusual
error pattern will decrease
exponentially the length of the protocol
like SH an option ok so here so let me
give you a couple of ideas that we use
um and for two just to plot these ideas
let's assume that we have a complete
graph ok so I think we have a complete
graph and I have two nodes as in this
awesome target and s wants to send end
bit T reliably in constant number of
phones obviously you cannot send the
base directly because this will take n
rounds it's too much but what he care
what s can do you can do the following
he can take these and bits just encode
them using standard error correcting
code this will give him like order of n
be
and now we know that even if each bit of
this order of n bits is again is being
flipped with some probability epsilon
then still it can be decoded with high
probability then the next thing is just
to use the network to relay this
information so instead of sending all
these bits directly we will start a
small chunk to the first node small
chunks to the second node and in the
next step they will all relay the
information back to p2 so in two rounds
we were able to communicate n bits
between S&T and we did it reliably so p2
will be able to Ethel so T will be able
to decode it with high probability the
second observation is that if we did
this thing on a complete curve then we
only used n edges of this curve right
which is a very small fraction of a
graph the graph actually has n square
links in a complete cloth this implies
that not only that s can talk with D but
also other parties can talk with each
other because they don't collide us just
too many paths that can be used
simultaneously this already gives a
solution to the complete graph which I
will not give the details on but it's
based on just splitting the network into
subsets of square root of N and relying
through this and this so this subset
using some routing scheme i will give
slightly more information about this but
i want to focus on the de regular case
not on the complete graph but they are
related so so it will make sense so okay
so let me just explain what I didn't say
in the last day in the last time so when
s wants to talk to t what he can do he
will just speak a subset of lettuce
square root of n parties I'll just relay
the information through these parties
not only this but while I stocks with t
also this node can use this p parties to
relay information to someone else back
to s for instance right because these
are totally different paths I not only
also these three notes can still relay
information at the same time that this
lean on sale information so we have a
lot of ways to shift information from
side to side and this is this allows us
to to complete you know to let everybody
talk to everybody as we did so this
happens a on a complete cough can we
take this idea to the D regular graph so
in the difficult curve it's it's not as
simple as it looks here because here I
can just pick three nodes they're good
relaying network they are connected to
everybody what happens in the D regular
graph so this is a do regular graph
let's say that s wants to talk with his
neighbor T now I hate it it makes less
sense to pick this guy to realize though
because s is connected to this guy but
this guy's not connected to take a lot
of elevation is that there are still
many many paths between S&T using this
relay and here we need the mixing time
so we actually show the many short path
there are many paths of length at most 2
m that connects SNT will give more
details about it in a second this joint
pass right but this is actually the
property we need we don't really need
the mixing time we need to have a lot of
disjoint short pass between S&T why do
we need them to be shot because as is
going to communicate message through
this pass or if this passes long it will
just income or blow up this will incur
blow up of like 2m which is is great if
m is constant
okay so now i'm going to do two things
first I'm going to steal five minutes
from the from the coffee break and don't
hate me that much and second I'm going
to just give you how this coding scheme
works in three simple steps okay so the
first step is the following we claim
that if you give me a list of certain
targets list it can be with with any
multiplicity but you in show me that
each dog doesn't appeal to many times in
this list so each node may appear in
this list only d over n times then we we
know we show that we can connect each SI
with its TI using a path of length 2 m
and moreover all these parts are jointly
edge disjoint so they don't interfere
with each other this is based on so you
Slava's local Emma to show this this was
also done in previous works but except
for that we have very restriction very
strict restriction on the on the length
we want the past to be very short okay
the second step says the following so
assume that I'm a party and i have d
bits to send but i don't need to this to
send these debates to the different
parties i only need to speak with d over
lambda different parties with lambda is
some power metal it's the same d yeah so
i have debates the same but only to do
over lambda different parties then we
show how to do it reliably with this
amount of rounds as with and high
probability m square logan pounds how do
we do it it's it's based on the same
relay that i was talking about so
just we take these debates we encode
them using some code and then we send we
use thousand one and send each bit using
this disjoint paths so we can send at
each each time we can send d / M of the
beats using this joint path so how do we
get this this number of vials of first
it takes em steps to go with this a2m a
pass right this is 1m and then square
becomes comes from from the fact that we
can only send to the / m parties at one
time so this gives us another factor of
M the log M is technicality and let's
just skip this one okay a last step so
we are not done because what we want to
do we want to simulate one round of the
noiseless protocol in one out of the
nonsense protocol each party has one bit
to send to all of these d neighbors
right and we cannot do this we can only
talk with D over lambda parties so in
the third zone we just show how to to
send one bit to the D neighbors by
applying thousand to and recursive times
so we do some moving bits from place to
place in order to fulfill this one round
so this is a sketch very very high level
sketch of how this scheme works let me
ND stock with with open questions so
what you can see in this talk that there
is correlation between the topology and
rate that we get off the coding and the
question is can we get a positive rate
for any topology the answer is probably
not and another question is is there a
difference between the random casts
the case and in that verse LOL case that
resists one of the end noise how how
things go there and how their the
topology effects Drake in this case okay
that's all i had to say thank you what
is the bed pallavi star so style has
degree n so yeah but Elvis naughty for
doesn't work and it's not good regular
so our scheme doesn't work as well and
let small mixing time but as we said
what we need is not the small mixing
done but a lot of parts between two
parties and style doesn't have a lot of
paths between two parties has only one
path between two paths this is a good
content or something so you seem to
always assume an undirected apologies
all right yes what about directed um so
we didn't think about it that much a the
paper by hose and Shulman they also
discussed the case of directed a
directed graphs and so in the drosophila
case they know how what to say how the
noise and didn't the right is affected
by the topology of directed coughs
senior's you need to know the topology
of the whole graph to simulate it right
is that true so is there any
decentralized version of this original
protocols look it I mean to some
certainty
I mean auto policy seems to be
interesting key is much larger than n so
you can just communicate say topology to
begin very soon it will be something
that's only of the order of N squared
and squared log n but then you need you
need some in Doctor Who protocol that
finds the topology if the parties don't
know it it's not revealed but yes this
is why is it like I could just find
there is very little if not sure we
should be anything from this on about is
where they keep out there is how
expanding to happen yeah there's a whole
series of paper say what the pending
group found freezing every subset of
this forward and others you know it was
right what even the empty set of paper
the other question I had is you said T
has to be much larger than n why is that
is that the only interesting case what
about t is much smaller than it really
because like it may be that you have one
arrow propagate said so assume that you
have one person like who wants to send
one be to everybody in the network so if
she is much smaller like one propagated
there is no way you can see that's not
sure in the mixing case right because
there you've got you can get everything
through the network very quickly all
right actually i take i mean if if if t
is my sausages and ends at you fine I
mean in practice if you're really doing
something t is probably much smaller
than and not large but if T's if T small
as it ends and you only really need to
know the topology around yourself right
right which is when you have this small
mixing time so maybe that's the case
you've kind of is more interesting units
thank Don and Clem and all the other